this constant fear-mongering of they're
going to reverse interracial marriage
and they're coming after gay marriage
yes uh that's what they're doing that's
really what they're doing it's just it's
incredible anyway
the Senate passed this Defense of
Marriage Act even though it's already
Supreme Court law there's a lot of
people saying that that it's actually
what they've now passed will be an
affront to religious liberty let's just
put that aside for a moment but just
listen to the hysteria yesterday at the
at the White House the elderly man
pretending to be President Joe Biden
talking about gays and what's happening
to gays in America
when a person can be married in the
morning
thrown out of a restaurant for being gay
in the afternoon this is still wrong
first off nobody gets married in the
morning people get married you're going
to get married in the afternoon to the
evening usually very few weddings take
place in the morning so I just like to
you know technically I think he's making
a little bit of a mistake there
um there is no evidence we did a whole
bunch of Googling yesterday
um of gay people being kicked out of
restaurants okay we have the equality
act like from
1963 or something like that
um nobody's being kicked out of
restaurants for these things it's so
nonsensical you're not going to believe
this guys most people when they open up
a restaurant or you open up a uh you
know a shoe shop you open up some sort
of store you're not trying to figure out
the sexuality of the people that are
coming to buy product you're really just
trying to move product make a little
profit get a little scratch in your
pocket have a nice weekend that's
usually what you're trying to do you're
not trying to open up a waffle house and
be like oh my God those lesbians got
married this morning no waffles for them
it's just nonsense